[Musik]
sein fall war so dramatisch und
unvermeidlich wie sein aufstieg
boris johnson war und bleibt ein
phänomen unter europas politikern blond
extrem intelligent hemmungslos tabu
brechen und außergewöhnlich schlagfertig
wir holen uns die kontrolle zurück als
londons bürgermeister und britische
aussenminister gelang es eben immer
wieder den fauxpas und die gezielte
provokation zur politischen kunstform zu
erheben
soll der britische steuerzahler etwas
stierkampf in spanien finanzieren
seine amtszeit als premierminister war
gespickt mit pannen kehrtwenden und
skandalen
johnsons persönlicher ehrgeiz und sein
charisma waren eine mischung die wahlen
gewinnen konnte oder referenten
entscheiden
als boris johnson 1 sein ganzes gewicht
hinter die brics it kampagne war nahm
der kampf eine wendung die nur wenige
erwartet hatten
diese entscheidung hatte ihn in die
downing street gespült lange halten
konnte er sich dort nicht am ende
stürzte er über partys in lockdown
zeiten die erschöpfung seiner
parteifreunde angesichts johnsons
fragwürdigen umgangs mit der wahrheit
[Applaus]
es gibt wohl nur wenige politiker die
eine szene wie diese überstehen können
ohne sich dabei politisch das genick zu
brechen
zunächst schien es dem damaligen
bürgermeister von london vermutlich als
guter werbegag während der olympischen
sommerspiele 2012 mit juni in jack
fähnchen in den händen auf einer
seilrutsche patriotismus und
sportlichkeit zu demonstrieren
doch irgendwie blieb johnson stecken und
baumelte dann eine halbe ewigkeit drei
meter über dem boden vor sich hin wie in
einer babyschaukel
der aufforderung ihm eine leiter oder
ein seil zu reichen
kamen die belustigten zuschauer nur
zögerlich nach
so ein foto von einem der
einflussreichsten
amtsinhaber im lande lässt sich ja nicht
alle tage schießen ein bedingtes york
für ihn ist alles ein scherz sein
auftreten allein sind schon ein witz er
nimmt nicht ernst wenn man sich
interviews mit ihm anschaut merkt man
rasch dass nichts was er sagt wirklich
zusammenhängenden sinn
aber aus der geschichte ihres wie auch
unseres landes wissen wie er dass
politiker die rationalität zu uns um
populistische effekte aufgeben ziemlich
gefährlich
es wäre fatal erkennen zu müssen als
boris johnson uns auf der grundlage
eines scherzes aus der europäischen
union geführt hat
es war jene nacht im juni 2016 die man
in großbritannien und ganz europa über
generationen hinweg nicht vergessen wird
[Musik]
jubel über die befreiung von den ketten
brüsseler bevormundung mischte sich mit
entsetzen über die entscheidung europa
nun den rücken zu kehren
und mit wut auf den mann der bei vielen
als der hauptverantwortliche für den
ausgang des referendums gilt
schande über dich boris wurde ihm dazu
gerufen
und ob es der mangelnde schlafe oder die
eigene überraschung war boris johnson
und seine mitstreiter wirken seltsam
verhalten und fast ein wenig unsicher am
morgen danach
an diesem donnerstag erst gestern habe
sich das britische volk für die
demokratie ausgeschlossen für demokratie
in großbritannien und in europa und ich
finde wir können stolz sein auf dieses
triumphgeheul hört sich anders an
hatte boris johnson etwa mit diesem
ausgang gar nicht gerechnet obwohl er
sich doch mit verve für den austritt
eingesetzt hatte
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wahlkampf kann boris johnson wie kein
zweiter
[Musik]
überall mit anzupacken beim mitzumachen
ist für ihn überhaupt kein problem
[Musik]
bürgernähe wirkt bei johnson nicht
aufgesetzt er vermag es mitzureißen und
man hört ihm zu man möchte ja auf keinen
fall den nächsten gag verpassen
die eu erinnert mich ein wenig an
schlechten seite unterhosen angekommen
solche die an einigen stellen zu eng
sind viel zu eng und
an anderen wiederum die geradezu
gefährlicher weise zu weit
sich über die brüsseler bürokratie und
den europäischen superstaat lustig zu
machen ist eine spezialität johnsons und
auch die nachweislich falsche behauptung
dass sich durch einen eu-austritt
wöchentlich 350 millionen pfund sparen
ließen die dann dem nationalen
gesundheitswesen zu gute kommen könnten
machte er sich zu eigen der spruch ziert
den wahlkampf bus & johnson legte sogar
selbst aktiv hand an den slogan zu
gestalten
dabei war im vorfeld lange nicht klar
für welche seite sich boris johnson
eigentlich entscheiden würde
jemand der das wochenende zuvor mit ihm
verbrachte hat mir berichtet dass er bis
zuletzt mit dieser entscheidung gerungen
hat er spekulierte wie die meisten
darauf dass die briten knapp für den
verbleib in der eu stimmen wer aber dann
beliebt bei den euro skeptikern in einer
starken position gewesen wäre später
einmal den parteivorsitz der
konservativen zu übernehmen
[Musik]
der morgen an dem boris johnson aus
seiner haustür trat und bekannt gab dass
er sich dem austritts lager anschließen
werde wird von vielen als der
entscheidende moment in der referendums
kampagne gesehen
[Musik]
ich bin zu der ansicht gelangt dass
nachdem ich 30 jahre über dieses thema
geschrieben habe nun die chance da ist
wirklich etwas zu ändern ich wünsche mir
ein neues verhältnis zur eu das meer auf
handel und zusammenarbeit basiert und
weniger mit diesem super start zu tun
hat nach langen qualvollen überlegen bin
ich zu dem schluss gekommen dass mir gar
nichts anderes übrig bleibt
er liebt es einfach im mittelpunkt zu
stehen die ganze gespannte erwartung die
sich bei dieser pressekonferenz vor
seinem haus aufgebaut hatte genoss er in
vollen zügen er war ernsthaft hin und
hergerissen vor seiner entscheidung aber
er liebt eben diese aufmerksamkeit schon
als journalist früher wie jetzt als
politiker und mit dieser entscheidung
machte er sich zum mittelpunkt hätte er
sich für die eu-freundliche
regierungslinie entschieden wäre das
nicht der fall gewesen insofern kam dies
seinem ego seinem ehrgeiz aber auch
seiner generellen risikofreude sehr
entgegen
boris johnson wendete sich also aufgrund
wie es scheint durchaus sehr persönliche
motive gegen die eu gegen brüssel
was insofern ein wenig verwundern mag
wenn man bedenkt dass johnson mit dieser
stadt viel verbindet
zwei jahre ging dort zur schule sein
vater war einer der ersten offiziellen
die nach dem eu beitritt großbritanniens
1973 nach brüssel entsandt wurden um für
die kommission zu arbeiten
ende der 80er kehrte boris johnson noch
mal zurück als eu korrespondent der
konservativen tageszeitung the daily
telegraph mit durchschlagendem erfolg
und zum leidwesen zahlreicher
zeitgenössischer und ihm nachfolgender
kollegen in der belgischen hauptstadt
als ich 1999 als korrespondent der times
nach brüssel kam hatte ich mit den
konsequenzen von borries wirken beim
telegraph von 1989 bis 1993 zu leben
boris einzige absicht war auf die
europäische union einzudreschen wo immer
es nur ging
sich über sie lustig zu machen sie zu
verhöhnen und zu verunglimpfen that
story schrieb geschichten die nur sehr
entfernt etwas mit der wahrheit zu tun
hat
manche von ihnen waren schlicht
haarsträubend zum beispiel wie europa
versucht großbritannien standardgrößen
für kondome aufzuzwingen oder
entschieden habe dass schnecken fische
seien oder schnüffler auf britische
bauernhöfe zu schicken um diejenigen die
zu schlecht riechen zu bestrafen
all diese geschichten hatten nur sehr
geringen wahrheitsgehalt
war auch die über den plan das
asbestverseuchte eu hauptquartier in die
luft zu sprengen was natürlich nie
geschah
all das sollte dazu dienen das bild
eines unbürokratischen eu zu zeichnen
die sich in die angelegenheiten
souveräner staaten einmischen
zahlreiche kollegen aus den damaligen
brüsseler tagen bescheinigen johnson
eigentlich bei weitem nicht so
europafeindlich zu sein wie seine
artikel vermuten ließen doch wie diese
in einem radiointerview später einmal
selbst einräumte hatte er einen
heidenspaß daran zu beobachten was seine
berichte der heim so alles anrichten
tatsächlich tat sich damals so einiges
im verhältnis großbritanniens mit der eu
margaret thatcher benahm sich im umgang
mit ihren europäischen partnern
zunehmend bockig
wurde aber ende 1990 selbst aus dem amt
geputscht
ihr nachfolger john major hatte seine
liebe not den zunehmend
europafeindlichen flügel seiner partei
im zaum zu halten und brachte die damals
wegweisenden maastricht verträge nur mit
mühe durch britische parlament
johnson führte mit seinen brüsseler
anekdoten den kampf innerhalb der
konservativen partei um die haltung zu
europa
eine bittere auseinandersetzung die bis
heute andauert und letztlich auch der
auslöser für das referendum gewesen ist
boris johnsons wirken in brüssel hat das
verhältnis der briten zur eu nachhaltig
beeinflusst und geprägt
[Musik]
das problem war dass diese berichte
lustig und unterhaltsam war der
telegraph liebte sie der euro-skeptische
rechte flügel der konservativen partei
ebenso und die chefredakteure anderer
zeitungen verlangt von ihren
korrespondenten dieselbe art von
geschichten
[Musik]
positives über die eu zum beispiel dass
sie dem kontinent einigkeit und frieden
gebracht hat dass sie die länder
osteuropas integrierte die
mitgliedsstaaten dazu gezwungen hatte
ihre strände und flüsse zu säubern und
jungen menschen ermöglichte überall in
europa zu leben arbeiten und zu
studieren
all das wollte niemand hören
und so entstand das zerrbild eine
karikatur von europa die 25 jahre
bestand hatte es ist als dann das
referendum kam wurde das wenn alles
natürlich wieder ausgepackt und noch
eine schippe draufgelegt
da machte boris johnson wahlkampf mit
hilfe eben dieser karikatur von europa
die er selbst erfunden und in der
britischen presse verankert hatte auch
inventar
sowie johnson als kenner der brüsseler
szene damals dieselbe ordentlich
aufmischt ist er auch mit dem britischen
politischen establishment verfahren
obwohl selbst teil der elite ist es
johnson immer wieder gelungen sich in
bester populistischer manier von ihr
abzugrenzen
wie 19 premierminister des landes
zuletzt david cameron ist johnson im
elite-internat eaton zur schule gegangen
besonders in latein und altgriechisch
zeichnete er sich aus und
im rugby spiel
auf ihnen folgt im typischen werdegang
eines britischen oberschichten
politikers boxset oder cambridge
in oxford studierte johnson
altphilologie und war vor allem auch im
berühmten debattierclub der universität
aktiv der oxford juni
und in noch einer vereinigung war
johnson mitglied dem sogenannten bowling
club einst meist feucht fröhliches
netzwerk vorwiegend ehemaliger eaton
schüler den blonden im vordergrund
erkennt man sofort der junge herr
stehend oben links ist david cameron die
beiden verbindet seit alten tagen ein
erbittertes konkurrenzverhältnis
[Musik]
ich denke das hat schon ein bisschen was
von shakespeare in der politik geht es
natürlich oft um persönlichkeiten
persönliche rivalitäten vor allem wenn
sie lange zurück reichen können durchaus
eine rolle spielen cameron musste wohl
denken dass es sich ziemlich einfach
macht indem er diese ist die politische
klasse nicht lächerlich schiene fährt er
hat diesen populistischen ansatz
bestärkt ihn belebt geradezu zum
erblühen gebracht
david cameron der zwar selbst ein guter
kommunikator ist an die schlagfertigkeit
und das charisma von borries aber nicht
heranreicht ist schier daran verzweifelt
dass der stets ein doppelspiel spielte
einerseits wollte er immer ein teil des
klubs der herrschenden klasse sein hat
aber nun selbst dazu beigetragen sie zu
stürzen
in dem sich johnson im referendums
wahlkampf gegen die regierungslinie
positionierte stellte er sich damit
gleichzeitig natürlich auch gegen
cameron was dem ganzen womöglich noch
die nötige würze verlieh
ich denke diese konkurrenz war vor allem
ein thema für boris johnson david
cameron war da entspannter er ist denn
das reiche establishment hineingeboren
worden er wusste um seinen status boris
johnson dagegen war ein außenseiter er
wollte und brauchte den erfolg unbedingt
und es wurmte ihn dass da dieser junge
war auf der schule zwei jahre unter ihm
und in oxford einen nobody der plötzlich
premierminister wurde während er nur
bürgermeister war er musste diesen
niemand ausstechen der jenen job inne
hatte der doch eigentlich für ist nie
gestimmt war es packende job days of
peace
in der auseinandersetzung mit johnson
unterlief cameron 2008 ein
folgenschwerer fehler
vielleicht um den konkurrenten in der
großen politik aus dem weg zu haben
drohte als damaliger parteichef der
konservativen johnson an für das amt des
bürgermeisters von london zu kandidieren
der nahm dankend an gewann die wahl und
konnte sich fortan auf dieser spielwiese
ordentlich austoben
[Musik]
in dieser rolle bemühte johnson auf
und londons zuschlag für die olympischen
spiele bot ihm eine plattform
selbst menschen die seine politische
auffassung nicht halten liebten ihn für
seine auftritte seinen humor und für
sätze wie diesen
und so rufe ich der welt zu
[Applaus]
doch es gibt auch durchaus stimmen die
johnsons acht jahre in diesem amt
kritischer betrachten die olympischen
spiele nach london zu bringen war die
leistung seines vorgängers in erinnerung
bleiben dafür viele sonst nur noch die
einführung eines neuen
doppeldeckerbusses
und jene leihfahrräder die sogenannten
boris bikes
[Musik]
seine größte leistung als bürgermeister
war überhaupt gewählt und gar
wiedergewählt zu werden als
konservativer in einer stadt die sonst
eher links welt und dass er zum ersten
mal als politiker ernst genommen wurde
aber wirkliche errungenschaften nun da
wurde viel von wohnungsnot und
verbrechensbekämpfung geredet aber die
kriminalitätsrate stieg und viele häuser
wurden nicht gebaut es vielleicht schwer
etwas zu finden was boris in seiner zeit
als bürgermeister wirklich zustande
gebracht hat
dennoch hätte es boris johnson dankbar
exit 2016 vom londoner bürgermeisteramt
fast direkt in die downing street
gespült
aber nur fast
nachdem david cameron nach dem
überraschenden referendums ausgang
nichts anderes übrig blieb als
zurückzutreten schiene weg frei für
johnson
er galt als aussichtsreichster kandidat
für dessen nachfolge bis ja bis ganz zum
ende jener denkwürdigen rede am 30 juni
lasst uns die chance ergreifen und dies
zu dem moment machen da wir uns mit
stolz geschwellter brust sehr welt
präsentieren dies ist die aufgabe der
sich der nächste premierminister dieses
landes stellen und
meine freunde die ihr so treu auf die
pointe dieser rede gewartet habt nachdem
ich mich mit kollegen beraten habe und
angesichts der machtverhältnisse im
parlament bin ich zu dem schluss
gekommen dass ich diese person nicht
sein
was war geschehen
hatte der kampf zwischen johnson und
cameron schon züge eines shakespeare
dramas war das was sich nach dem
referendum abspielte an klassischer
tragödie nicht mehr zu überbieten
michael gohl ehemaliger justizminister
und dragset befürworter hatte mit
johnson im wahlkampf ein erfolgreiches
tandem gebildet
dass johnsons kandidatur für das amt des
premierministers unterstützen würde
schien selbstverständlich
doch dann entschied sich golf
urplötzlich selbst ein hut in den ring
zu werfen und boris den dolch in den
rücken zu stoßen
[Musik]
lachende dritte war großbritanniens
innenministerin theresa may die hatte
sich im referendums wahlkampf zwar für
den verbleib in der eu ausgesprochen
dies aber eher verhalten
nun ging sie ausgestattet mit einem
schuss eiserne lady attitüde als die
einzig glaubwürdige kandidaten aus dem
blutigen gemetzel um das premierminister
amt hervor
und wartete dann alsbald mit einer
faustdicken überraschung auf die
ernennung boris johnson zum
außenminister
[Musik]
die verblüffung über die entscheidung
war groß
dies war die reaktion einer
oppositionspolitikerin als sie während
einer veranstaltung live davon erfuhr
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die zeitungen im in und ausland hatten
ihre helle freude
[Musik]
und dem sprecher des amerikanischen
außenministeriums
entglitten kurzzeitig die gesichtszüge
als er von der ernennung hörte
[Musik]
maze kalkül war es einen harten drexhage
befürworter wie johnson mit ins boot und
damit in die verantwortung zu nehmen und
ihnen gleichzeitig mit diesem amt
aufgrund vieler auslandsreisen fernab
vom täglichen praxis geschehen zu halten
doch diese rechnung ging nicht auf
jonsson blieb maze erbittertsten
widersacher immer wieder warf er ihr
knüppel zwischen die beine paktierte mit
erz konservativen der tory partei und
trat wegen meinungsverschiedenheiten
über die verhandlungsstrategie der
premierministerin in der praxis frage
nach nur zwei jahren im amt aus dem
kabinett zurück
wie sein plan indes funktionierte das
nicht enden wollende drama im parlament
maze wiederholte scheitern mit ihrem mit
brüssel ausgehandelten deal war sein
gewinn
im dritten teil
wusste mit einer kompromisslosen braig
sitzhaltung gewürzt mit einem schuss
patriotismus und einer prise
zweckoptimismus würde er sie beerben
können
was die leute in diesem land wollen ist
ein guter deal sie wollen am 31 oktober
aus der eu austreten und die
abgeordneten im parlament werden
einsehen dass wenn wir nicht am 31
oktober austreten die sehr ernsthafte
konsequenzen für unsere demokratie hat
es dauerte dann allerdings noch ein paar
monate länger doch mit dem plakativen
schlachtruf der exit dann
gewann johnson im dezember 2009 10 die
parlamentswahlen mit einer satten
mehrheit
nachdem jahrelang gitarre waren die
briten einfach des brh exit müde und
kauften ihm das versprechen ab dass es
das nun endlich gewesen sein
am 31 januar 2020 feierten ein paar
hartgesottene praxis fans den
offiziellen austritt aus der eu auf den
noch eine elfmonatige übergangsphase
folgen sollte bevor er faktisch
vollzogen war
auch der premier speckte offensichtlich
im glück dieses erfolges zumindest
versuchen kritiker so die tatsache zu
erklären dass seine regierung die
warnzeichen der heraufziehenden corona
pandemie komplett verschlief
[Musik]
just am tag der exit party hatte
großbritannien seine beiden ersten
bestätigten corona fälle es sollten
millionen mehr folgen
johnson zögerte lange beschränkungen
einzuführen am ende mussten sie doch
kommen die langen fahrten lockdown
der premier betonte er schüttele
weiterhin ungerührt hände
machte die länge des erforderlichen
händewaschens an geburtstags liedern
fest
und landete dann selbst als cupid
patient auf der intensivstation
bis heute hat großbritannien die höchste
zahl an coruna toten in europa zu
beklagen wäre da nicht das impfprogramm
gewesen mit dem das land rasch und
effektiv aus den startlöchern kam die
korona politik boris johnson schließe
sich im rückblick nur als chaotisch bis
bestenfalls konfus beschreiben
hat zu beginn der korona krise ziemlich
herum gestimmt hat daran besteht kein
zweifel und das ist jedem aufgefallen
aber dann fing sich wieder einigermaßen
und wurde zu einem jener politiker die
verhindern wollten dass das land in der
krise überreagiert und dem wirtschaft zu
großem schaden nimmt
und tatsächlich sind wir jetzt in der
lage mit den schultern zu zucken und mit
dem virus zu leben und nicht jeder aber
viele leute würden sagen dass er da die
richtige entscheidung getroffen hat das
impfprogramm mit dem er sich andauernd
brüstet hat mit ihm eher wenig zu tun er
hat mit kat bringe meine sehr fähige
frau auf den richtigen posten gebracht
sie hat uns die impfstoffe besorgt den
rest hat unser nationales
gesundheitswesen erledigt ein wenig
glanz fällt auf ihn ab weil er zu dieser
zeit der premierminister war
das loblied auf das impfprogramm wurde
auch dann noch unermüdlich weiter
gesungen als andere europäische nationen
die briten beim impfen längst überholt
hatten es war die letzte
verteidigungslinie eines premiers der
durch zahlreiche skandale immer mehr in
bedrängnis geriet
[Musik]
da war zum einen der spektakuläre
versuch der regierung das parlament
durch eine art zwangsurlaub auszuhebeln
um ihre berichtet pläne ungehindert
durchsetzen zu können bis sie vom
obersten gericht des landes
zurückgepfiffen wurde
nicht weniger dreist die bemühungen
johnsons ein fraktionskollegen dem
korruption vorgeworfen wurde durch eine
regeländerung vor der suspendierung zu
bewahren
und bis heute ist der vorwurf nicht vom
tisch johnson habe versucht sich die
extrem aufwendige renovierung seiner
wohnung in der downing street mit
zweifelhaften mitteln finanzieren zu
lassen
am ende aber waren es eine reihe von
partys im regierungssitz die boris
johnson das amt kosteten mehrere
weihnachtsfeiern und umtrunk im garten
während dem rest der nation per corona
regel strenge kontakt beschränkungen
auferlegt waren
[Musik]
eine misstrauensabstimmung seiner
fraktion überstand johnson anfang juni
gerade noch so
der tropfen der das fass zum überlaufen
brachte war dann aber die sogenannte
spitzelaffäre
dem stellvertretenden fraktionsführer
crispin wurde in mehreren fällen
sexuelle belästigung vorgeworfen
wiederholt dies johnson verbreiten er
habe von den anschuldigungen nichts
gewusst als er teamchef beförderte dies
aber stimmte nicht da waren die geduld
und das vertrauen seiner parteifreunde
endgültig aufgebraucht
weil er eben so etwas wie ein clown
entertainer sagten die leute so ist er
der boss ein filou halt aber wir mögen
ihn er ist lustig und
so wurden seine moralischen defizite die
im land und seinen kollegen durchaus
bekannt waren beiseite geschoben
als es dann aber zu all der aufregung um
die partys in der downing street kam was
an sich allein vielleicht gar keine so
große sache gewesen wäre die tatsache
dass er ein lügner ist nicht
vertrauenswürdig und von zweifelhaften
charakter den menschen wieder ins
bewusstsein
viele haben gedacht sei ein houdini ein
magier der machen kann was er will man
wird es ihn schon verteilt doch das land
als erkannt was für ein mann er wirklich
ist
es passt ins schillernde bild des boris
johnson dass weder sein zögern bei der
pandemie bekämpfung noch die nicht
gehaltenen versprechen über die vorzüge
des brh exit zu seinem sturz führten
sondern etwas frivoles wie ein paar
partys in der downing street
und immer wieder dieser laxe umgang mit
der wahrheit